it's it was exclusive for um engineering
um amazon engineers until maybe the last
couple years but at the time we we
started the
secreted the first computer version
course that mlu had
we had maybe like 25 or 30
brilliant engineers in the room for uh
for two months and then five of them
joined me and the first seed of that
team uh we were working on different
projects with um
more with amazon retail um tons of
projects in that like supporting the
search and research function and they're
searching for products and understanding
what are in the products and there are
internal toolings in there and then we
had a couple projects a few projects
with amazon robotics and then earlier in
amazon go as well and then the team
started drawing probably around like 30
or 40 people by the time i left uh and
yeah that's uh things has started you
know this way again passion to do things
and then just
uh
i got people stamped to actually do with
my deja which was really exciting
yeah that's great how you discovered
your passion for cv and then you were
able to sort of
um work with that and work it into your
career i think that's a
that's a great thing
when you can sort of follow your heart
you know at the same time that you're
building your career so it takes takes
some people a long time some of us a
long time to learn that and so um i i
really respect that
i guess that what might have helped is
that i worked as a again as a consultant
for some time you get to live a life
where you're not really looking for
stability you're looking to do a great
job get the best out of the experience
you're having and then uh not
necessarily like move on to the next
step but but more and more is like okay
where think more about your career
because it's not really tied to a
specific company you can drive it
anywhere that you want so that has
helped me a lot in making these
decisions
got it
well um i i don't want to skip synapse
because synapse was the next stop in
your in your career and i know there's
some of the origin story of kalena that
kind of comes out of some of these
learnings so even though synapse was i
think the smallest company that is sort
of in the line of your work experience
um talk to us a little bit about like
what you went there to do and achieve
and what you learned
yeah i think like synapse has been one
of the best experiences i had in my
career uh it was a small team when i
joined i was revenge
the exciting thing about it is you're
working again on the whole full stack we
were so we were selling the whole box we
were doing ai on edge detecting threats
in x-ray machines so in cprt checkpoints
and airports and others uh so we have we
our product was the software and the
aips that's detecting the the prohibited
items and threats and then the hardware
that we're actually attaching to to um
to the x-ray so we it was an exciting
project here i get to i was head avenged
but in a small team
and after having been a manager at
amazon
you don't get your hands dirty uh in a
day-to-day basis i have to scratch this
edge on my uh night uh
hustle but at the time uh with synapse
i get to play with everything and then
we got exposed and now we were not you
start selling products life-threatening
products you detect a gun you detect a
knife if you don't detect it it goes out
up on the plane or it goes inside the
space so
you our customers our
business teams like every like the whole
ecosystem is very thorough with this
testing process understanding how things
are happening so we were pushed by the
market and by our ecosystem to think
about this problem really early on at
synapse and that was the scene of almost
everything i've done after that
because if you let one
one prohibited item one dangerous weapon
or gun um you know on through through
the x-ray machine and onto the airplane
like that could represent a catastrophic
failure yeah of of of of the process and
and the tech and the plane um to be
honest for everybody nobody's happy with
this and and
the the the customer or it's like the
security checkpoints they will not let
that happen anyways so they would just
thoroughly test your product and then if
it doesn't fit the bill then they will
not go if you especially if you do not
understand
when you're talking to head of industry
or on the product more than even like
the business if you don't understand
exactly where your model is going to
fail and where your chances are or
even worse when you have a model and
then you give them a new model here's an
update oh what did you improve uh
98 to 99 doesn't mean much so that just
we we realized this whole thing that
we've been working on the way we've been
using a global metric to describe our
our product for ourselves and for our
customers has to change it that doesn't
work it will not work this way the
company wouldn't have sold one piece of
our product with this approach
well i wanted to get into this insight
more because i know this is one of the
key insights around the the formation of
kalina
because it's fascinating but but before
we do that um
just talk to us a little bit about the
challenge the other challenges of
working at a small startup like synapse
when you had come out of
larger companies to date in your career
like what what was the startup
world like for you and what did you
learn there that was sort of unique
beyond just the tech the tech learnings
well the challenges are the the reasons
that i joined so i don't know if there
are challenges or advantages but the
challenges are um
you have a lot to do and uh it's a wide
span of things it's not just one piece
that you're focused on especially my
role again i was managing all
engineering so i had to do a lot of
things my day to day again it's exciting
whether it's a challenge or it's an
exciting thing but it was exciting for
me that you don't have you're switching
context a lot i i don't i didn't work on
for example on the software salon or the
aips along with the hardware we work in
everything like my date is just really
not
a traditional day it was very exciting
but again it comes with you know less
stability and uh
more like you more pressure from
customers directly as opposed to if
you're in a larger organization you're
usually just building something and
maybe seeing reviews or something so we
were much closer to the customers uh the
challenges are obviously
you have a small team you cannot do
everything in the world so even our
testing
methodology here that we wanted to put
on a product we we couldn't invest in
building an internal tool which is
actually it's a big problem even for
larger companies but like basic
to basic tooling is now open source i i
i i'm grateful to the open source
community they have tons of
tools and which you know we certainly
have to stitch that but the point is it
saved us a lot of these efforts but the
biggest challenges our biggest
challenges are the ammo space is is very
big a lot has to be done for the product
and from the infra to the product and we
had to figure things out with very low
very small team
so so you had this key insight that a
global metric for accuracy
might not be the best way to to test or
to explain the weakness of a
machine learning model
um synapse ended up getting acquired by
palantir
you ended up leaving and going to
rakuten which i assume was a larger team
than synax where you were synapse where
you're the head of the ai the ai team at
racketon which is a obviously a very
large gaming company so
um how did what you had seen
was sort of was the pandora out of the
box with you um leaving how did that
affect how you approached this larger
much larger team at uh although maybe it
may be less mission critical ml at
racketon
uh i joined jakuten with the testing
problem in might i have been
thinking about this and we will talk
about it when we jump into how we
started calling up we've been thinking
about it we researched the topic we had
something that we wanted to fix it and
then
hygiene recognition is an exciting
project to build the entire ai team and
ai infra so we i joined data with a
large team and then
the biggest key insight that i got from
there is the problem is not on just
envision side this the problem is not
because you're a small team the problem
is not because it's life-threatening
application the problem is there is a
little motivation right like for a
life-threatening application yeah that's
clear we know the motivation but for
other like larger organizations then the
motivator is the roi the investment on
especially these larger organizations
they usually tend to be skeptical about
what are we achieving with this uh with
this investment now that's not miserable
if you're not testing right that's what
we noticed uh so
again we we got hit again by another
signal of how this blueprint that we put
in paper uh for testing is going to be
valuable for
vision companies smaller companies and
larger companies our world working on
structured data nlp audio data so
it was super clear for us we had to cut
our journey short after we have built
their ai platform and then we
after a year i just
i say me because you andrew with me uh
but
what is my co-founder but yeah we and
then we create ourselves and start
working on kubernetes
got it so so tell us the story about
andrew and how you guys met and where he
came into the picture
yeah andrew and i were this is the third
time we worked together we worked
together at synapse um he's a software
engineer and uh after that we worked he
came from valencia so we hired him from
palantir into synapse and then we uh
he we joined the rakuten together he was
the head of the software team and then
when we and together we've been thinking
about this problem you know for for a
few years and then we found that okay
this is the right time to do it and then
we just quit our jobs and we jumped
around colena full time
got it
so um
i want you to
you know kind of explain to the audience
um in a bit more depth um this key
insight that led you to start kaleena
um and i think you you have a few slides
that i've seen bumping around before
that um i think more clearly sort of
articulate this problem because it's a
it's a significant i think when you
first explained this to me
um prior to to date a community fund's
investment in kalina like i was pretty
blown away that that not more people
were sort of thinking about ml testing
um and model performance this way so why
don't you um why don't you show us a few
slides and sort of walk us through the
the big aha moment
yeah well actually the big aha moment
was a kind of an embarrassing moment uh
and stressful moment so i will share it
with everybody now
you just share my screen
okay you see that now
it looks looks dangerous
so yeah we have uh this is an exact this
is a real story uh we were demoing we
like one of the earlier products we were
detecting a guns in x-ray machines and
then we spent months looking at these
statistical metrics you know where you
look at the accuracy precision recall
and then we came up with represented to
the tsa a model 99
accurate or f1 score and then we missed
this obviously when in the first test of
the demo they were like excited okay
let's play with this new toy so it
dropped a gun and an empty bin right and
and then this is how it looked on the
screen and we missed it now you cannot
come back from that like unfortunately
the loss is trust and irreparable you
cannot you cannot say there's a bug
really there's no response here and
there was as an as head of energy there
was no response from me when i'm looking
at that or my sales team and my
leadership so it really was an
embarrassing situation very stressful
and then we spent months trying to
investigate and retrain and then the
problem with this is like you you you
put data in the test you capture it and
then you there's no guarantee that this
bug won't appear again because it could
be regression how how would i not see it
so it gets it gets really messy at this
so when we started looking at why this
is happening
we took a look at our current evaluation
approach i believe
people have here in the room can tell us
if they have something different but i
believe this is a standard ml evaluation
approach came from the lab to our uh
industry trying to personalize it which
has a lot of flaws so what we do here is
we
we as engineers we run we we have some
benchmark data sets we run inferences on
them and then we we
spend days or weeks staring at these
error logs losses and validation loss
and come up with some magical global
metric that globally didn't tell us like
the gun like is 99 so what is the one is
the one percent the most adversarial
case that was intuitively what we
thought the case is like it could be
anything so that that fails to tell you
like really we started looking at this
number it means nothing when we tell our
customers this is the number it means
nothing to them we tell our business
teams engineers it really doesn't give
direction to anybody to do anything and
the main problem here is two main
components here that has to be you know
reinvented if you will the the frozen
benchmarks these we we tend to freeze
our benchmarks so we can compare apples
apples and progress so they tend to be
like one block and frozen and they're
not evolving like training data and
they're not evolving like the production
data so they always stay behind and then
this one bulk of data produces one bulk
of metric like one metric now so that
global metric
brings this problem which is literature
called uh hidden certification problem
now this is basically what it says is
that the model within one class
it has highly valuable performance for
its subclasses so for the gun
gun from different orientations top view
side view and so on uh occlusion
occlusion same thing here for this in
their paper uh they they shared the an
example of uh chest x-ray
and then they have
the blue curve right here that's the
global metric or the aggregate metric
and they don't care about that they care
about
the this green curve a uc curve that ha
that has no chest straights but it has
been biased by another
subclass that they don't care about so
they always are tracking this blue class
and they are they end up failing
silently which is the most painful thing
when you're building an engineering
product
so we have what we ended up doing is we
we wanted to look at the important
questions that are difficult to answer
today with this global metric problem
and this is across the board like
engineers scientists product managers
customers everybody dealing with an ml
product they always ask these questions
what are the failure modes of this
bugs if you will
and then when you run models of
different versions and retrain what has
improved what has regressed gives
direction to to engineers to know what
to do and to customers to know to make a
decision
and then if
the biggest question that we always ask
when if the model improves from some
number like 96 to 99 does this mean that
the model improved
all scenarios of the class we don't know
that like what we saw you will see the
next slide that that's not the case and
then when you have a feasible models
which model should deploy to that
environment to that customers that
number 99 998 doesn't tell you you have
to deploy the 99 because it could be
doing better in in that just one model
can be a better fit for a customer
environment than the other and then when
to know like check park this model is
ready to be deployed all these questions
are not answered today
now what we are proposing is we want to
we want to shift the paradigm that we
live into in now into a test case-based
evaluation so that the life we live in
today involves these arbitraries but
test sets
and even balance or ambulance even if
you balance it invest the time balancing
it but it's still one block but we want
to transfer that into uh highly
uh curated testing scenarios in our test
cases so in the gun example instead of
having a bulk of done images we want to
stratify that into gun in empty bin
that's the case we saw now and then top
view front view all different angles and
different occlusion levels different
blur that's just a slide of you know six
or seven cases but we saw that if you
have the right tooling you will have for
each class tens of
cases so you're able to have really high
resolution test results that fits the
product criteria that you are looking
for so something like this if we
um if we had had that approach
when we were demoing we would have seen
that model a and model b one is
presenting around 97
on a global metric some accuracy or
recall and then another one is 99. we
had no other information than deploying
99 demo in the 99. now if you have
created this product criteria and the
test cases you will be able to have this
high resolution results and you say you
know what 97 is doing much better in
this case i would say for demo that and
then when we pushed for the higher
inclusion as a team to improve occlusion
in general we and unburned we found that
we improved in that but we regressed in
an easy case that was silently we didn't
see that even though that global metric
was showing higher numbers so we learned
that without this higher resolution
results you won't be able even able to
make any decision about which criteria
is important for the product which is
not how engineers are able to go ahead
and fix this bug
as opposed to having to you know shoot
in the dark and uh going through a lot
of iterations
yep
makes sense um thanks for thanks for
sharing that
yeah sure
so um i you know it i think it quickly
becomes apparent to folks that if they
want high resolution
understanding of what their model is
detecting and when it's not
this approach that you're proposing
it basically looks like
you have to brute force the model you
have to brute force the model with a
expansive set of every
possible thing you can imagine you want
it to detect and
it's no wonder people don't want to go
down that road because that sounds a
little bit complicated
or daunting
you know how do you build a library of
images and how do you
manipulate images or objects you know to
get the right
the right orientation or how do you sort
of adjust lighting and blurs all these
things some can be done you know at the
digital image level some can't right so
um
i i i think it's easy for someone to see
the wisdom
in this approach but probably like to
actually implement it in the real world
might be a little bit challenging would
you agree
absolutely like we when we were so a
step before starting kulena i um
i was writing the final chapters of my
book and it's in vision systems and i
wanted to fix this problem it's been a
pain embarrassing pain for me
personally and then i worked with a few
researchers who were working with me on
the book and then we
the idea was like let's think about ml
testing publish a paper or chapter in
the book and then we talked to i would
say like 100 teams or something and then
we we found that
outside maybe like 20 of them were
pushed by the market to
across the board all have the problem
but different severity level obviously
but maybe 20 of them have thought about
the problem and then they landed
separately on the same conclusion which
is the let's try to stratify our data to
get higher quality and the others are
like having a problem it's just still
not yet uh thought about like how we get
out of
this box
but we we notice the teams that want to
solve the problem they end up
creating
taking the much brute force approach
like you said the much expensive and
time and cost approach which you have to
metadata all your data so you if you're
looking on face information problem you
have your screen on mine if you want to
look at
search test how
the model is doing for male
with the beard for example and
headphones so you have to go on my image
and have somebody tag that say beard
images so you'll be able to stratify
your data later or
charge it manually so it's it's really
painful process it ends up not being
implemented and that's how we felt about
it we thought we're going to publish a
paper and then we realized it will never
be implemented without actually a tool
for it which is something we shopped for
for years
so we we realized that okay let's give
this uh
process its best shot let's build the
tool for it it has to be a holistic
approach it has to deal with the like
you said with the data stratifying
creating representative testing
scenarios or test cases managing these
test cases and then being able to
compare models store models and some
eval store and results and then compare
models uh debug models find insights and
highlights it can't happen with one
piece so that's that was the reason that
we definitely this is we we don't see
any um we don't get any pushbacks or
challenges the industry kind of agrees
that this is the right way to test
machine learning products the problem is
it's very tedious and time consuming if
you don't have a tool for it got it so
so before we talk about the tool because
i want to dive into that a little bit
more but before we do that um
talk to us about sort of your best
practices or your mental model that you
use when you think about how to stratify
the data i think you've used the term
subclassing the data with me before
um
so if maybe there's something smarter i
presented it as brute forcing the model
with just
every possible image you could think of
but obviously there has to be a more
analytical way to to do it and to break
down your data than that can you walk us
through some of your
tips um
as to how to think about your data
properly so that you sort of make sure
you get the major cases covered
absolutely so
i will say it in the world without
kolena because this is the world is
we're living now
for most people
so we first thing you want to think
about like product has to be more
involved now the we're giving them like
they have the chance now to think about
what exactly that they want their
building for or who are they building
for are you building
in in a car detector right like you're
building a car maybe it's indoors only
so you don't need to worry about the
weather and light conditions maybe
you're building a car in some kind of
community small smart community so you
don't care about detecting you know
larger trucks in front of you so first
think about the environment that you're
that you're deploying in and the
requirements so then software you think
about requirements first right so think
about requirements what are you building
for and then
you say i want to detect a car a fire
hydrant a bicycle a pedestrian these are
four classes today's world is you you go
ahead and collect a lot of images of
cars a lot of images and so on and then
you train and test which is a very
expensive process and the lifecycle is
around training what we want with the
the ml development cycle to be around
testing so it's a test centric ml
development
meaning that you start with writing the
requirements create test cases for those
so go ahead and collect data for these
environment requirements that you're
building for only and then
test before training test few models
usually we start with some open source
models or even like basic models
test with some models and then find
these
failure modes and then go ahead and
collect data and train for these
phenomenas that saves a ton as a
starting point of time in data
collection labeling and training
iterations gets you to a faster motor
market exactly know what you're building
for now definitely it's harder to have
if you have four four classes you break
each to 20 test cases you're talking
about 80 and then usually gets
hundreds and thousands of test cases
it's really hard to manage that within a
spreadsheet or writing it down so this
is where the platform comes in but in
general uh start with the requirements
create test cases test
and then from the test now you go back
you have higher resolution results and
then go back and collect data for the
results so this is test driven
development for machine learning models
basically that's what is what this is
we we try yeah that is one yeah it is
test driven development uh it has its
own connotations in the software world
uh some are fans some are not fans i'm
not here to argue about how it works in
the software side
but
on the the anal side it's it's a
different nature of building the product
most of the time is going towards
collecting and labeling the training
data and then training
before testing so you spend you put a
lot of overhead on in the beginning of
the process blindly without knowing
exactly what you're testing for so it
becomes really critical on the ml side
and much easier engineers we don't like
the test server development software we
understand that i'm sending overhead
about it but in in the ml side it
doesn't add the overhead if you have the
right tooling obviously for this but
either way even if you don't it's less
work in collecting data which is for you
and wrangling the data and understanding
what the data is about
and so what about folks who would sort
of um
question just the fund this fundamental
insight right like it's essentially it's
like you're building sort of a white
list of
things that you want the model to detect
and those presumably are known to you
ahead of time because they become the
requirements for the model
um
does that not leave other things sort of
on the table that you you never thought
of at all like does it sort of imply
that you need an extremely comprehensive
view of what this model will check and
is that realistic in all in all use
cases you know in all applications
yeah so you asked the right question
that led for us to build the product
right because
it has again this for this to work well
uh to ask people to change how they are
doing things it has to be a holistic
approach it solves every piece and then
the first question like i said always
the first question we get is okay i
don't know what scenarios i want to look
for right i have my testing
face detector i have my test data and i
know i can just break them by race and
gender like that's like 10 if you'd like
to wifi or something
right so that's the best you can do and
then
for you to learn more about the failures
you you deploy that you get failures
from production and include that in your
test cases
in interesting process but for us to
solve this problem and that's that's the
world before without kalina but what
we're doing here is we add we we're
showing a lot of insights on the
failures so usually you start with all
the bot let's start with all faces and
then we we're going to tell you hey we
we show you insights on where are the
patterns of failures are happening
without labeling the data meaning that
we tell you
you're feeling when the person in this
on and the image is looking up or
looking on the side when the person is
including their math these are insights
that the platform automatically provides
without the data being labeled i have to
uh insist on that because that's the
main thing that you need to save so run
the first uh on quality data or the best
guess that you have and then within a
few months of insights and we've given
you insights on this data and take this
insights and look at the the gallery of
images that we built for you and then
create this data create a training test
and then after that within a few months
we've seen that teams start with maybe
five to ten test cases based on their
understanding of the problem and then
within a few months they have a couple
hundred two or three hundred and then
you see the resolution report where you
get to another uh challenging problem
for the from the platform side is within
these hundreds of test cases how do we
show you the importance of first but
that's a good problem to have
so it sounds like what you're saying is
that the the cleaner product is
basically
designed to help you create
and manage these batteries of tests
that are
well structured and well thought through
um
and also that represent sort of what
your what your parameters and your
criteria for the model actually is that
is that fair
absolutely we want to make sure that we
help teams manage their test data
there the way it makes it representative
so you don't miss anything in production
and
it's easy to do it right that's the most
important thing now
test data has been always like an
afterthought after training data we
always think more about training data
distribution bias and all the these
interesting areas but the way i see it i
think testing data is more important
than training because the point of
every scenario that you're building for
has to be represented in the test data
but it doesn't have to be represented in
the training data because the whole
point of the training data or training
on your network is that you're teaching
it to generalize you're not teaching it
to memorize things right so you start by
representing any scenario that you're
expecting in production and you test
data before going ahead and collecting
because that's much less data than
having to train on and then you might be
doing well then good if you need to fix
that it doesn't have to be the answer is
always collecting data it could be the
answer some respect first find the
problem so managing their data into test
streets and test cases versioning that
and making sure that they are always
looking this is the source of truth of
the data and it's representative to
their production environment is the
biggest piece one of the biggest pieces
that we're focused heavily on
well that's really fascinating because i
think that just turns the conventional
wisdom on its head because
you're saying that if we paid more
attention
to the test data in the first place like
we could essentially control our own
destiny
that model
and just throwing
massive amounts of training data
models just because that's the
it's a low fidelity
only way we know how to make the model
smart in ambiguous ways you're saying
start from the testing data first
um which represents exactly what the
model's going to detect and and we
really sort of get to impose
our will on that model in a much more
sort of calculated analytical
way which also creates
a massive benefits and not needing to
collect and label all these massive
reams of training data that may impact
the model in ways that we actually don't
need at the end of the day
oh you you described it much better than
me i like to control your destiny
statement because it's definitely yes
like we we think about uh like shipping
with confidence but actually i would i
would as an engineering manager i would
love to control my destiny i would love
to not get a request from
uh business teams leadership customers
why are we failing here you told me we
improved on this three three versions
ago did we regress yeah i don't know i i
my answer is has to be okay i'll get
back to you for like a week an
investigation or two weeks going through
images one by one which is a really
painful process i would love to control
my destiny
well that's great um so so then who's
the main user of kolina is it the
ml engineer is the data scientist
is the model developer
is it a test um a person is sort of a
test function like how does how does the
tool
sort of touch different um parts of the
org
yeah we look at the space because you
mentioned the scientist engineer
developer we look at the function right
like the titles are
they can vary from organization to
another but we're looking for the two
main users at the starting point that
we're focusing on
the person who's building or training
that's their data scientist machine
learning engineer i'm a developer
however we call it and the product
manager this is the person who
understands what they have been before
just staying outside the the ml room
knocking on the door how are we doing
here can you can you tell me the
performance in that model what was the
performance on the model we gave to that
customer and then
everybody's not happy that pm is not
happy the engineers are not so we're
giving them we opening this door for
them and we're opening that box for them
giving them
complete access to create test cases
test models and then debug right debug
actually product managers can very well
and they are
most suited to do this we are connected
to the problem much better so we want
data scientists to test their models
using kulena find failure modes real
quickly within minutes and then
save the time on labeling and iteration
by focusing on on the right problem
that's for data scientists and product
managers now we're giving them a way to
be able to manage the product the way
they want create the actual backlog and
say i want to improve and detecting cars
at night and then i want to prove they
can cars at night and rain from rear
view so there are tons of scenarios here
that they can actually start managing
their products and seamlessly get all
the answers they want without having to
wait uh under an engineering backlog for
an answer
this is awesome because we've talked at
data council for the last couple years
about what a potential like product
management track would look like um what
does it mean what does it mean to create
an ai product
and how are ai products different than
other software products that we've been
sort of accustomed to building over the
last you know 20 years
um and i think this starts to get to
that point which is
um
you know it's only through like this is
an example of a process that sort of
brings the product manager
um into the actual
model development process and gives them
some insight and even control over
you know the the outcome and the output
of what that model determines and i can
see how
um this would be like really a welcome
thing for product managers who wanted to
be involved before but were kind of
locked out just through the black box of
what we think of as
many bumbles in the process of building
them and then testing and deploying them
yeah we've seen product managers are
very excited finally it will be to have
like a a vote and how things are
happening usually they have to step
outside but things are looking very good
and i hope now that you asked me about
the rules i hope there's a new role that
comes in that is qa for ml
they will be like that it has to happen
either way because now testing is
becoming an important thing and then the
more
we we notice that people are testing
much more now with with class or you
would need and debugging much more and
creating progress much more so
a dedicated role there will definitely
add much value to the whole ml workflow
for for a team
so i i keep kind of probing because i'm
trying i i love the insight as you know
but i keep trying to figure out like
like where it breaks or where it breaks
down or what the trade-offs are
um so
so maybe another way of phrasing that is
talk to us about the current your views
in the current model explainability
landscape right there's lots of
companies
that do model monitoring that do model
explainability that
are sort of involved
in parts of these
these metrics in this process to create
business confidence
in models
but usually they're sitting sort of at
the end of the workflow and they're
trying to capture
data drift and statistical metrics and
other performance indicators kpis on the
model um just talk to us a little bit
about you know are you complimentary to
them or how do you sort of see yourself
playing along in this in this this
ecosystem with other kinds of partners
and tools and just what are your general
views on that approach
yeah we
so if you look at the
the workflow ml workflow very like 30
000 review kind of view
um
we have like main buckets the data
management piece enabling versioning all
this data management piece and then the
training or experimentation piece where
it comes like tools like uh
comedy email with some biases and others
and like and different platforms and
then the deployment part so i skipped
the testing here so this is the the the
space that we live in today and then the
deployment part becomes these companies
in deployment and then comes again
monitoring observability
now explainability specifically i'll
take a step back and then we talk about
it
it comes
i see it as a debugging tool because
what is this explainability it's uh and
same thing for observability very very
close to it it's basically uh creating
relationships between the failures and
the features
now features in image
what are the features in this image is
basically
nose eyes maybe some others around so
the the best you can do here is apply
some uh lime or sharp or any of these
explainability
algorithms just to highlight where the
model
adds more value to what features to say
that this is a male or female or
something so you will see you will see
that on a granular level on image level
as a debugging tool it's something that
we will throw in and our debugger uh
debugger the explainability piece to
complete the piece of node debugging
uh it can be
more useful outside the
outside the unstructured data maybe in
structured data because features in
structured data you're talking about if
you're given a loan you're talking about
age
gender
location and so on you can tie failures
by by feature which is understood by
humans but how are you going to tie a
feature in an image and say we failed
because whatever i saw this lamp next to
me has a problem
so it has the explainability
observability um both have uh monitoring
is a different thing in my mind but
explainability and observability are
everything is new in in the whole
workflow they are specifically more new
and uh things are
we're trying to shape where things fit
well i i don't see
um i see maybe i was
expandability as a complementary
debugging piece in in our debugger
that's not a testing definitely approach
got it
um and then obviously on the you know to
sort of continue the the the question
and sort of this layer on the other end
of the spectrum you have all the
data prep tools and labeling tools and
um you know tools that help sort of
label data sets for training
and obviously
colena can inform those tools or at
least inform
to what extent you need to use those
tools on what amounts of data so
obviously you're in this interesting
spot in the in the value chain
and
i think it's fascinating that
you don't really see that anyone else
has popped up that really claims to be
doing model testing
in the same way that you are at least
not to your knowledge
um yeah i mean we there obviously
obviously like we are still thinking so
maybe our people didn't hear about us so
maybe we don't hear about other people
but in general uh testing has been a new
thing and and everything in industry and
in tooling and even in their side
follows the same patterns or trends in
the literature side and literature
started talking about testing in the
last couple years because it became a
problem now we're trying to
productionize
our products um
so testing is new we are new we are
ahead of or on top of the wave starting
trying to
tell people how things are we see things
tested because most teams are like
saying or tools that are saying we are
doing testing they are looking at the
current approach of we are helping you
visualize our
roc curve we have visualize you know
these give you metrics it makes the
process today's process easier the tools
that we see in the space they make
today's process easier we are telling
people that we have a new process
that will be easier and we'll actually
give you the results because i don't
believe
working on the global metric
i i would love if any of the teams that
hearing us
message me tell me it's working great
then i have learned something new but
the vast majority i've seen when you are
working on a mission critical
application you have to certify your
data you have to treat your data as
especially this data much give it much
more attention than the training data
got it
well i want to zoom out just a little
bit um i think that's all very well said
and and comes across really clearly um
but but to zoom out a little bit if
you're creating this sort of new product
in basically a new
newish category
um of the ml tooling stock what sorts of
values does your does your company hold
from a product standpoint like how do
you sort of
infuse the early team
with the right values to be able to sort
of rise to this challenge how do you
look at that as a founder and ceo
well we have like our mission is like
focusing on like it's a clear simple
mission where everything we're doing is
focusing on achieving that which
basically is helping teams build high
quality models
faster and shipping with confidence
i don't want people to be shipping
engineering product still engineering
product we don't know how it will work
it says the idea of
um opening the box you don't have to
open the box to know how it works inside
but you know you can definitely test
that box close box still backwards but
you test how it will perform
rigorously to have that confidence so
the whole talk again i don't i know it
takes us on a tangent of your question
but
it fits into your question about
observability on others the whole talk
about opening the box understanding
how the models make decision is valuable
maybe for researchers but if i am a
manager or a product manager or a
company or a team productionizing a
product i have customers i look at i
want to test this product i want to know
that it fails to detect a stop sign at
night i don't care that it didn't see
the feature of a circle uh sign or
something
so the idea of test shipping with
confidence so three things is high
quality models faster than in today's
world with even with the rigorous work
that you're gonna put it will be faster
and
ship with confidence
i mean i think you should just embrace
this as a tagline i think the tagline
for kalina should be
opening the pandora's box of machine
learning models like i think i think you
should just go all in
i like it i like it
definitely
um so so you know speaking a little bit
more about the product again um what are
some interesting architectural decisions
that you made in in the creation of your
product um i'm curious if there's
anything that you think is significant
there that you can share with us
we actually so the the most significant
significant thing that we noticed is a
couple months after we built the earlier
version of the product
and uh we noticed so this is on the
engineering side now i'm happy to chat
on the product side but on the
engineering side we
we were building a product and then
testing data is usually much less than
the training data so we're expecting a
couple hundred thousands maybe a million
but we saw with our
we'll talk more about or if we get into
the product but with our testing studio
or data study that we built that uh
teams start with these you know a couple
hundred thousands of data and within a
few months they have
10 15 million uh images or you know data
points now that kind of like uh
load or scale on data for one customer
after a couple months it's projected to
be a billion within a few months and
then tons of customers more data is
better because you know you'll be more
certain uh on or that these results are
accurate we don't wanna uh withhold that
so the biggest thing is like okay how
are we gonna scale really quickly on the
data side to you to be able to we found
partners in that and to help us with
this part as a small team uh but that
was the the most interesting engineering
architecture
decision on that this on the product
decision is like that studio the biggest
problem that i showed you guys the slide
of like paradigm shift from you know a
world that we live in today to certify
test cases how are we going to get there
like in today's world usually you have
to you learn something about your
problem you write down your labeling
instructions you work on the problem you
learn more so you go ahead and re-label
everything again and then re-label
everything again that's not going to
work it's never going to scale you stop
at like most teams that have implemented
this process stopped at 10 15 20 most
test cases you don't get the actual
value
so we this is where our data studio come
in place uh and that was one of the
first pieces that we worked on and that
has been the most helpful piece so you
think about it as a creative space that
you go in there with your data and and
be able to slice and
select scenarios specifically black car
at night from rear view and rain
and then uh we reverse engineered
photoshop a little bit so you're able to
apply some preservations and and
augmentations to find to create that
scenario like simulate that scenario
right and that's now you is not is not
uh synthetic data it's your real data
but and as a real uh augmentation so it
simulates the real scenario out there so
that is the biggest piece where we were
thinking about how do we solve that
shift from
the world today of one test test data
set into a stratified list of test cases
so this is the cleaner studio which is
your your core product that helps
companies
sort of find manage create
batteries of training sets um
specifically designed um against their
criteria for that model
yeah correct it's uh one of three
components to complete the full solution
that's great
well we're
we're almost out of time muhammad
unfortunately um
i just wanted to ask you um a couple
more things what's the biggest vision
for kalina and its products that you see
at this point
so when you look at testing it it's
different than training or data
management testing has a lot of
stakeholders a lot of people want an
answer
about how the product works
we covered engineers building a product
and product managers but their managers
want to look at the whole fleet and how
things are going leadership one want to
be able to track
you can't track progress more we went
from model the model from 80 to 90 that
doesn't mean much but you want to be
able to track we have improved in these
features that's my product and we are
lacking these features and we are
improving so leadership won't want a
piece of that so that's it's 360 degrees
within the organization
and then when you zoom out looking at
the industry it's not just the team
that's building we've been always
talking about the company that is
building the product but the the company
that's buying their product or a the
customer buying the product today what
they're doing is the the way they test
it is they look they pull some images
together and hundreds even thousands if
they're like doing a regular job and
then they're trying to do some some a
lot of work in actually validating the
product for comparing different products
before they buy it or different uh sdks
so that customer like our customers
customer like the first the company that
is buying the product is definitely
something that we will
need to cover and independent auditors
today are testing the same way they are
using and they are benchmarking
companies
and based on that these companies are
building customers it's a
like a legitimate approach that or legal
companies that are independently testing
models and regulators so the the idea of
it's that we that's really where the
name came from because we saw that
it's 36 degrees inside the organ inside
the company and 360 degrees inside the
uh
the space we're focusing only on the
company now but the vision is to create
this reliable platform that
stamp approach or make sure that people
can come in there compare different
products compare different models before
they decide to use or deploy if you're
building
yeah that's that's huge um that's an
exciting vision for certain
well we'll definitely encourage folks to
check out calena
dot io um you'll be
launching stuff soon this is sort of a
preview of
um you haven't even really officially
launched right so this is like a yeah we
have a selfie page the website is coming
up in the next three weeks great awesome
so this is a preview for the data
council community so so thanks for
joining us i'm sure folks will reach out
to you if they have questions um because
i think a lot of your thoughts in this
space are fascinating and i always i
always enjoy our conversation so so
thanks for taking the time here
thanks for having me have fun
um and to our audience thanks for
joining us uh in two weeks we'll have
another dc thursday on the story of
presto and trino with dane sundstrom
from starburst data so don't forget to
join us then um you can hit subscribe on
the bell and hit the bell icon on
youtube so that you're notified when we
go live again otherwise you can find all
of our previous episodes of dc thursday
on our playlist on youtube
so thanks again to muhammad and we'll
see you all soon